so with the amazing spider-man 2 coming
out I figured it'd be a good idea to
have a discussion on the main
antagonists of this film and I figured
it would be a good idea to really kind
of highlight how he is a dangerous foe
to spider-man but how he's also one of
spider-man's weaker foes due to the
weaknesses that he has and so in this
video we're going to be discussing the
character electro so before we get too
far into this discussion there are a
couple very basic principles in
electricity that we need to discuss the
first is the function of an electrical
capacitor and the second is the concept
of resistance so an electrical capacitor
is something that takes in an electrical
charge reduces the electrical charge and
then outputs that reduction of
electrical charge so let's take your
hello let's take your computer as an
example I think that's a really good way
to go let's say that you have assembled
a computer and you have a 1,000 watt
power supply and your video card only
requires 400 watts of power in order for
it to function now the question you
might be asking yourself is what keeps
your power supply from discharging a
thousand watts of power into your video
card and blowing it up well that's what
the electrical capacitors do on your
video card if you look on your video
card or any kind of computer hardware
you'll see these little copper heads so
to speak and what these do is they take
in that thousand watts of power and they
reduce that thousand watts of power down
and they discharge it out in the form of
400 watts of power and that is in effect
how an electrical capacitor works now
for the most part all electrical
capacitors work the same way whether
you're talking about a capacitor in a
computer or something in the Hoover Dam
it all pretty much functions the exact
same way now resistance is exactly what
it sounds like resistance is the idea of
electricity running in to resistance or
coming into contact with resistance as
it passes from one
object to another now with regards to
this example the best one I can use or I
guess the best kind of analogy I can use
is the one that my supervisor used for
me when I first started my job let's say
for example that you have a great big
huge tank full of water and you have two
connections on this tank one connection
is for a one inch hose that's one inch
in diameter the next connection is for a
one inch hose that is one foot in
diameter now if you were to connect the
1 inch hose you would get far less water
coming through that hose than if you
connected the 1 foot hose this is
resistance the amount of current you can
pass through an object when it comes to
electricity electricity follows the path
of least resistance and something like
copper has a much lower resistance than
something like rubber so let's say for
example that you had a material that was
composed of both rubber and copper if
you were to analyze this in some form of
machinery that would allow you to
observe the transfer of electrons as
electricity went through the material
what you would see is you would see the
electricity going through the copper
instead of going through the rubber
because rubber has a much higher
resistance rubber is equivalent to a 1
inch in diameter hose copper is
equivalent to a 1 foot and diameter hose
so with that being said let's get into
the video so electro is one of these
guys that a lot of people consider to be
one of spider-man's most dangerous foes
but I don't look at him that way I
really kind of look at him as one of
spider-man's weaker foes because despite
the fact that he is capable of taking in
virtually an unlimited amount of
electricity and then discharging up to a
million volts he is still restricted by
the principles and the inherent
weaknesses of electricity and in fact
during the first battle that electro and
spider-man had spider-man wore rubber
gloves and sprayed him with the water
hose and that's how we beat him not much
of a a fight there it's really kind of
anticlimactic when you think about the
character and how he played out but
electro is really kind of he's kind of
like juggernaut in this sense of course
he's very intelligent but
is really kind of someone that utilizes
his incredible abilities for mundane
goals Elektra was previously a guy named
Maxwell Dillon and he was an electrical
lineman that is to say he's the guy that
you see on top of electrical lines who's
hooking up cables and wires and running
cable and different stuff like that
there came a point in which one of his
co-workers was stranded on a line and
Maxwell Dillon agreed to help him but
only under the condition that his
coworker would pay him for it so his
co-worker agreed to pay him and Maxwell
Dillon began to climb the pole in order
to get his coworker out of a bond so
that his coworker could get off the line
safely during this time there was kind
of a freak storm that was taking place
and a Maxwell Dylan was struck by
lightning when he was struck by
lightning he gained the ability to
manipulate vast amounts of electricity
but once he gained this power he
basically used it to start robbing banks
and to really kind of gain great wealth
and that's how he came into contact with
spider-man because he was in effect a
bank robber and to me this is really
kind of indicative of what you see with
a lot of villains in the realm of Marvel
Comics especially when you're talking
about villains who are comparable to
weaker superheroes when it comes to
someone like spider-man of course
spider-man is not an astronomically
strong character and so you have to have
someone who is proportionally strong to
spider-man and so I think that's one of
the reasons why Elektra was written the
way that he was the ability to discharge
1 million volts of electricity is more
than enough to kill a human being but if
the despite this ability despite the
fact that he can discharge this much
electricity at one time the fact that
Spiderman came to feed him by spring him
with a water hose and wearing rubber
gloves is really kind of indicative of
this character how kind of having a
balance I think he really is one of the
more balanced characters now when it
comes to electro and his engagements
with spider-man there were a couple
times you know of course the first time
he defeated him or I'm sorry he lost the
hands of spider-man the second time he
lost the hands of spider-man and from
here he really kind of began to involve
himself in the task of using numbers to
defeat spider-man that is to say teaming
up with other villains the sinister six
being one of the more notable examples
and Maxwell Dillon of course by his very
nature is kind of a loner he doesn't
really want
up with people but when he's kind of
faced with the circumstance where he was
constantly defeated at the hands of
spider-man he really didn't have much of
a choice usually when he engages
spider-man it's really kind of a
cat-and-mouse game and he ends up
engaging spider-man in an area that's
most conducive to his abilities so think
places like electrical power plants
places where he can recharge his power
with very little effort because with
electro his power is passive meaning
that he does not have to actively engage
in charging him turning himself up as
long as he comes into contact with
something that can discharge electricity
his body will automatically charge
itself up for him and it's really kind
of interesting the way that his power
works of course he can't transfer
himself through virtually anything that
conducts electricity and of course he
can travel along power lines and things
like that by using electricity to kind
of propel himself but with the normal
human body that is to say you were
myself of course we have something
called adrenaline and a drilling in
drilling is kind of a secretion by the
ooh I'm not exactly sure which organ it
is that secretes adrenaline but suffice
it to say whenever you're in a state of
high Durex say for example you're
walking down the road and as you're
walking down the road you see a car
coming flying at you you'll get a
metallic taste in your mouth you'll get
a heightened sense of things things
might slow down that's adrenaline
rushing through your body you kind of
have this heightened understanding of
everything that's going on and your body
is kind of in fight-or-flight mode with
electro instead of adrenaline he has
electricity so the more excited that he
gets the more ramped up that he gets the
more powerful he gets in terms of his
ability to manipulate electricity but
again because of the very fact that he
does exist according to the laws of
electricity he has a lot of weaknesses
so with that being said I really am kind
of interested to see how Jamie Foxx
plays the role and the amazing
spider-man 2 because electro is kind of
a mainstay I mean he was like the the
sixth villain that appeared I think he
actually appeared in issue number six of
spider-man he was one of the first few
villains that that spider-man faced and
so I'm really kind of interested to see
how it's portrayed because he's really
kind of a mainstay and he holds a
special place and a lot of the hearts
and minds
spider-man fans so I'm going to go ahead
and this commentary to an end hope you
guys enjoyed it and if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace